Ana: Hoy el café no es solo lo que tenemos en la taza; es el protagonista histórico. El café transformó la economía y le dio al Estado costarricense una base material para crecer.
Mateo: Exacto. Desde la década de 1830 el café se vuelve motor económico. Conecta al Valle Central con el mercado mundial y crea una élite exportadora que combina producción, beneficiado, comercio y poder político.
Ana: Pero el texto hace una distinción importante: el café costarricense no se asentó igual que en otros países centroamericanos. Hubo élites y concentración, claro, pero también pequeños y medianos propietarios.
Mateo: Esa estructura menos polarizada ayuda a explicar por qué el liberalismo costarricense tuvo una base social relativamente amplia. No era igualdad plena, pero tampoco el esquema extremo de latifundio y trabajo forzado que marcó otras historias.
Ana: En ese contexto llega la Constitución de 1871, la más longeva de la historia del país. República unitaria y representativa, división de poderes, derechos individuales, propiedad privada, libertad de expresión y petición.
Mateo: Y también un compromiso religioso: catolicismo como religión del Estado, pero tolerancia de otros cultos. El liberalismo costarricense no rompe de golpe con la tradición; negocia con ella.
Ana: El Estado liberal invierte en infraestructura física: ferrocarril al Atlántico, puertos, carreteras, obras urbanas. Pero el ferrocarril trae una gran pregunta jurídica: ¿cuánto puede ceder el Estado para obtener modernización?
Mateo: El Contrato Soto-Keith lo muestra. A cambio de ferrocarril, el empresario Minor Keith recibe administración por décadas y vastas tierras en el Caribe. El Estado compra futuro, pero paga con soberanía económica parcial.
Ana: Y ahí aparece el banano. La infraestructura que debía conectar al país también abre paso a una economía de enclave. La compañía bananera genera empleo y divisas, pero en el Caribe opera casi como poder propio.
Mateo: El liberalismo habla de igualdad formal ante la ley, pero tolera zonas donde el poder real no es exactamente el Estado, sino una empresa extranjera. Esa contradicción no es menor; anuncia la cuestión social.
Ana: En paralelo, el Estado crea infraestructura jurídica: Código Civil, procedimientos civiles, Código Penal, Código de Comercio, registro de propiedad. Es la idea liberal de ordenar la vida social mediante ley escrita y codificación.
Mateo: Ahí se nota la tradición romanista heredada: el derecho se piensa como sistema legislado. El juez aplica la ley; el legislador organiza la sociedad. Codificar era modernizar.
Ana: También está la educación. La reforma educativa liberal, con Mauro Fernández, propone escuela primaria gratuita, obligatoria y laica. Es un proyecto de ciudadanía, no solo de alfabetización.
Mateo: Y provoca conflicto con la Iglesia, porque quien controla educación controla imaginarios. La escuela pública laica forma al ciudadano del Estado liberal; la Iglesia temía perder autoridad moral y social.
Ana: El comercio exterior completa el cuadro: café hacia Europa, importación de bienes, banano hacia mercados globales. Costa Rica se vuelve pequeña economía abierta antes de que esa frase existiera como eslogan.
Mateo: Pero el precio fue una sociedad excluyente. El sufragio era restringido; mujeres, pobres y analfabetos quedaban fuera. No había legislación laboral robusta, ni seguro social, ni protección general frente a enfermedad o vejez.
Ana: Entonces el liberalismo construye Estado de derecho, educación e infraestructura, pero no resuelve la desigualdad material. Su grandeza y su límite vienen juntos.
Mateo: Y por eso la historia no se queda en 1871. El edificio liberal será ampliado cuando trabajadores, católicos sociales y reformistas empiecen a decir: la libertad formal no basta si la vida concreta queda desprotegida.